I think it's sort of like going to
America back in the 1400s it's it's
totally crazy but I think it will happen
and if you recall those first trips to
America were commercial voyages people
are looking for gold in India and stuff
like gold and spices perhaps one of the
big commercial drivers is going to be
all the minerals in the asteroids and
whether it's Christopher Columbus or the
internet or all these things they're
driven commercially and then they have a
huge impact way beyond with that
original commercial into this way
I think we'll turn outer space into
inner space but yeah we we are probably
going to well there's a reasonable
argument that we're going to create a
clean useful life supporting atmosphere
on Mars sooner than we will on earth
because on Mars we have no politics and
we have no incumbent establishment so
it's easier to experiment there and get
it right on earth the moment you start
changing things around you you run into
people who liked it better the way it
was or what have you probably this this
century it would take 30 or 40 years to
terraform Mars get a couple of
billionaires to fund it because the
government won't and then it's going to
end up being more biology then we're not
going to go put giant air blowers on
Mars we're what you need to do is
genetically engineer plants of various
kinds that will take the minerals on
Mars and it take the oxygen out of the
the compounds the oxidized compounds and
stick it into the atmosphere and figure
out what level of different kinds of
gases you need to make it breathable to
humans and to have the right it's sort
of light sensitivity that you will
capture the right amount of solar energy
to make the temperature habitable and so
forth